>>Kristy: Uh, hi everyone. Thanks for coming
to today's talk, "Do It Pro Bono" with Aaron
Hurst, right over here. This talk is part
of the Optimize Your Life initiative. Are
folks familiar with Optimize Your Life? Yeah?
So it's again the global initiative that aims
to provide Googlers with education and programs
to help them and their families to get and
stay healthy. So actually for folks on VC
if you could mute that would be great. Thanks.
So to see all of our upcoming Health@Google
speakers and topics, check out goto/OYL and
also, let me see if we can move this along.
We do have a survey where we'd love to get
feedback from folks on this talk, on other
talks that you'd like to see as well, so if
you can just at the end of the talk go to
go/health@survey for a 30-second survey and
let us know what you think. So I'm pleased
to introduce Aaron Hurst, a globally-recognized
social innovator and leading architect of
the growing pro bono services movement. Aaron's
career is dedicated to challenging and empowering
the private and public sectors as well as
individuals and organizations to drive our
collective social, environmental, and economic
progress. So a lot of work going on over here.
He's the founder of the Taproot Foundation,
which is a non-profit organization building
the national pro bono marketplace and leading
the global service movement. He's widely known
for his thought leadership and civic engagement,
non-profit management and corporate social
responsibility, which is definitely something
Google's very interested in. He's also both
an Ashoka and a Draper Richards Kaplan Foundation
fellow. He's also been formally recognized
as a leading social innovator by the Aspen
Institute, the Commonwealth Club, and many
others. Aaron currently serves on the boards
of Reimagining Service and BoardSource. He's
also a featured blogger for the Huffington
Post and he's coauthor of the children's book
Mommy and Daddy Do It Pro Bono, which a lot
of you guys have grabbed out here. And he
did that with his wife, Kara. And after the
talk today, Aaron will be graciously signing
books, so if folks are interested, you can
just come over to the table. And that is quite
an intro for quite a man, so please join me
in welcoming Aaron.
[applause]
>>Aaron Hurst: Thank you, Kristy, it's a great
to be here. I'm actually gonna go back up
to this one. I, which topic am I? I was looking
at these different logos. You got, OK, is
the first one cooking? Cooking. Fishing. So
you like have fishing classes? Weight lifting.
Religion and dancing?
>>female #1: Meditation.
>>Aaron Hurst: Meditation. Just give me the
weight lifting. Who can bench press 150 in
the room? Is there? No one? Yeah? Got one.
Well, thank you all for coming today. It's
a, it's an honor to be here and it's great
to see Google investing in you as whole people,
not just as employees and the work you do
from 7 a.m. till midnight, but the work you
do in your own life between midnight and 7
a.m. [audience chuckles] So it's just great
to see that they, they care about those few
hours. So thank you. I also want to thank
Google for all the support you've given the
Taproot Foundation over the years through
ad words and other philanthropic programs
that you guys do. So, much appreciated and
it's been great to have you as a partner in
our effort to, to make pro bono service part
of what it means to be a business professional.
And I wanted to try to explain sort of quickly
what Taproot is before I go through my whole
spiel, but we actually have a plant, Stanley
back here. And Stanley, you want to stand
up for a second? This is Stanley.
[applause]
>>Aaron Hurst: So Stanley actually just came
up to me right beforehand and he actually
worked at a non-profit called Oasis in, in
Oakland, right? And, which is a recipient
of three pro bono service grants that the
Taproot Foundation did for his organization.
One was around how to install a sales force
database for them to help fundraising. One
was around branding and marketing for the
non-profit. And the third one was around their
HR systems. And this is really what we're
all about at Taproot, is helping business
professionals help non-profits with critical,
functional needs. And Stanley can tell you
how horribly it all went, but that he still
loves us. So you got now like an example of
someone who is now a Googler, I think as you
call them, but who came out of the non-profit
sector. Hey Seth, what's up? So anyway, I
just gave you a sense for, for who we are.
So I'm gonna be signing books, but I wanted
to start off by doing a little reading of
a couple of the pages of this book. And I'd
actually love two volunteers. This would be
like an opportunity for service right here.
We got one. Come on up. He has an organ for
LA it looks like. Is that a, is that a heart?
>>audience volunteer #1: It's a stomach.
>>Aaron Hurst: A stomach. Like Godzilla, I
love that. Need one more. Come on up. So we're
gonna do a reading and I, I think you guys
will do better justice than I will, so actually
if you come on over here where the microphone
is. I'm gonna page through this and your name,
sir?
>>audience volunteer #1: Josh.
>>Aaron Hurst: Josh, you are now seven years
old, and
>>audience volunteer #2: Mary Ann.
>>Aaron Hurst: Mary Ann, you're gonna be a
parental figure today. So I'm gonna go through
each of these and if you can just read the
child part and if there's an adult part you
can act it out or whatever you feel moved
to do. So, here's the first one. This is for
engineers.
>>female #2: Jump up to the mic.
>>Aaron Hurst: Yeah, come on up so they can.
>>Josh: My daddy is a computer programmer.
He makes it so you can find things on the
internet. He also built a website for a group
that helps to save elephants and other animals.
>>Aaron Hurst: He could work here. Except
for he'd probably have a better computer,
but, it's a little dated. Why don't we just
rotate? We'll do the next one here, so, the
next.
>>MaryAnn: So I'll be the child again? Yeah,
ok.
>>Aaron Hurst: Yeah, go for it, let's do that.
I forgot that it's just all--
>>MaryAnn: My daddy makes ads for companies
to help them sell things. He says it is marketing.
I saw his ad on TV for a new car. He volunteers
to help foster kids, too. This is a sign he
created to help some kids find a new home.
>>Aaron Hurst: Fantastic. A couple more here.
Sales. Show us your best sales voice.
>>Josh: My mommy [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>MaryAnn: As a child.
>>Aaron Hurst: A little bit deeper like you
really mean it.
>>Josh: But as a child.
>>Aaron Hurst: Yes, of course.
>>Josh: My mommy is a consultant. She flies
around the world to help companies solve difficult
problems. She took me to this play. She helped
them get more people to come to the theater.
>>Aaron Hurst: What a mom. I think this is
the last one.
>>MaryAnn: Ok.
>>Aaron Hurst: Close this with dramatic flair.
>>MaryAnn: Ok. My daddy is an HR manager.
He helps to hire people for jobs at his work.
He uses his skills pro bono to help injured
soldiers get new jobs when they come back
from war.
>>Aaron Hurst: Thank you, that was.
[applause]
>>Aaron Hurst: Does anybody have any acting
tips for them? Just anything you'd like to
see improved for the next one? I know you
guys are into professional development, so
I wanna make sure. Pretty good? Ok. Thank
you both. I appreciate, appreciate the reading.
So my wife and I created this book a couple
years ago because we both had little kids.
We'd just had a. We both. Of course we did.
We had little kids and we realized in reading
children's books that there were two things
that were missing. One was that every children's
book was about astronauts, ballerinas, policemen
and firemen. There were no kids' books that
were about the jobs of a lot of the people
that we knew. And a lot of those people, like
if you're an HR manager and a kid asks you,
what, you know what the hell is an HR manager?
Which is how my kid probably would phrase
it. There, there was no way of describing
it or talking about it. And it really was
a disservice, 'cause therefore like every
kid just wants to be a fireman, and none of
them were inspired to be great HR managers,
so we saw a need for that. The second piece
was that there weren't books about celebrating
not just what people do in their office setting,
but what they do to use their skills to make
a difference and about setting that precedent
in the eyes of a child. And realizing that
marketing is not just about selling cars,
but it's also about using marketing to help
that foster kid, as we talked about. So we
realized there was an opportunity here for
a book that pretended like it was for kids,
but really was for adults to help them have
that conversation with kids. But also our
hope was to inspire parents to think of two
things. One, what would your child? How many
of you actually have kids in the room? I know
at least one. Fantastic. Breeding. I love
it. Breeding smart people. I love it. That's
good. The, there's actually a guy, who's,
he's actually up in Menlo Park, it was a lawyer
originally actually that inspired this. He
said, I asked him why do you do pro bono work?
Why do you on top of working 70 hours a week,
or whatever it was, why do you go out and
do pro bono work? And he said it was because
his kid, who was like seven, asked him what
he did for a living and he said he didn't
like the answer. He said I wanted to figure
out how, how my kid looks at what I do for
a living and making sure they felt great about
what I do. But the secondary piece is he reflected
on himself at seven, and the dreams he had
when he was seven and what he wanted to be
and then looked at what he was actually doing,
and saw a mid-life crisis coming, right? When
he was suddenly gonna realize he'd gone off
on this track and hadn't fully invested in
his values in who he is. And what's wonderful
about pro bono, it's not about quitting your
job to go become a nun. It's about doing the
great work you do in a commercial setting
at your job, but realizing you're developing
skills and giving those back in a much broader
setting to drive social impact and having
those things blended into your life. And that's
really what this book was all about. So I'm
excited to be signing copies afterwards. And
hopefully it'll lead to discussions with your
own kids about what you do. It has other professions
in there, these are some, some highlights.
So that does the closing thing on the book.
What do your mommy and daddy do? So it just
encourages you to think about, you know, your
life, to think about that question and how
you want to answer that question. And it's
a really profou-, it's the most simple, but
most profound question, 'cause it is again
both the voice of your child and your inner
seven year old that's in you thinking about
and judging your life. Which is probably the
most judgmental voice you can possibly have.
So the big message I wanna leave you with
today, I'm gonna go through a number of slides
here, but. Does anybody know who these two
folks are? Yes.
>>female #4: The peanut gallery from the Muppet
Show.
>>Aaron Hurst: The peanut gallery from the
Muppet Show. That is exactly right. They are,
they represent the old, the old white guys,
so we sort of always think about as sort of
like traditionally involved in leadership,
traditionally involved in philanthropy, etc.
And they had, these guys specifically, but
most people, this idea that you should learn,
earn, then return. How many people have heard
that expression? Learn, earn. Seth has. Joel.
That's it? This is, I'm gonna dispel a myth
you did not even know was a myth. I mean how
often do you get to do that? This is fantastic.
So as I, conventional thinking in American
business that you should first learn. You
go to school, you get in debt, you learn a
lot of stuff. Right? Then you stop learning
and you start earning. And you should just
dedicate every waking hour to making money,
making money. And some day you're gonna be
fabulously wealthy and then you start to return
it back to society. Right? That's sort of
this gen, there's a general philosophy. And
if you go to Wall Street, even you know I
think here in Silicon Valley there's a lot
of that attitude of, I don't need to worry
about giving back now because later on I'm
gonna have so much money, I'll be able to
give then, and that's what my goal is, to
like accumulate wealth so that some day I
do that stuff. Well, let's just wait until
then. Now I'm just, I gotta make money. So
there's like 100 flaws with this logic. Right?
The first most obvious one is that if you
get hit by a bus at 24, you never got to like
experience the wonder of giving back, right?
Because you always assumed there'd be the
next day. But not everyone's gonna be able
to like, to make it there and also you may
not be able due to life circumstances, be
able to return, you're not gonna be the next
billionaire. You're not gonna have the resources
you think you're gonna have. So it's also
based a lot on this false premise and optimism
of like I'll always have more later. Things
are hard now, but I'll always have more later.
Which is also a fallacy. It's also a fallacy
'cause it's based on the assumption that you
should stop learning when you graduate from
college or business school. That that's sort
of your learning opportunity and then you're
just like gonna go to work. Which I think
also in the contemporary business world, you
have to learn every day. You have to learn
how to be better at what you do. You have
to learn more about yourself. So I really
see and what I profess is the idea that you
should be learning, earning and returning
every day of your career. That every day you
should be looking at what can I learn today?
What can I give back? And be able to obviously
pay the bills so you can send your kids to
school and make sure they've got food on the
table. But that we need to integrate these
things much more into our lives and as part
of our identity. Does that make sense? Alright.
Anybody, is anyone in the room an economics
major? Sweet. We've got two. So you have to
help me with this one. Oh, this is a visual
for it, before we get to it. This is a basic
idea of present value of service. So, be honest,
the idea of present value, does that ring
a bell? Yes. What is, what is like at a high
level of present, what is, what does it mean?
Share with your fellow Googlers.
>>female #4: [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: So, to repeat that, basically
you take something in the future of value
and you discount it to what it would be worth
today. So for example, the way I think about
it is, if you invest $100 in the stock market
today versus $100 ten years from now, you
will have accumulated all that hopefully additional
return over those ten years, so that $100
is worth more now than doing it then, right?
So the basic premise here is, and this goes
to the learn, earn, return piece, your serving
right now has a much bigger impact than if
you do it ten years from now. If you wait
till you retire, you will have much less of
an impact, not just because of the volume
of what you do, but the compounded social
interest, if you will, of that service. So
this image I think illustrates it well, which
is, this is a picture of New York City in
about 20 years when the streets are fully
flooded from global warming, right? So it
shows like what it's gonna look like once
the sea level rises and all the streets become
flooded. So, if you think about it, if you,
right now work with an environmental organization
to help combat climate change and fight to
save the ozone and our natural environment,
we might actually prevent that water from
seeping up onto my, the streets of the city
I live in. Or, 10 years from now or 20 years
from now we'll probably need you to volunteer
to be like a gondolier for people going to
the hospital, 'cause they'll need like a gondolier
service to get to the hospital, right? So
the impact of your service today is infinitely
more valuable than it will be in 10 years.
Another example of that, and these are hyperbole
obviously, you take a kid, like a disadvantaged
kid is in a tough spot, has a lot of things
going against him at say age four. You could
be a mentor for them today and like try to
help get them on the right track and help
support them, or if you wait 20 years, you're
likely gonna be doing what I did, which was
teaching creative writing to inmates in a
prison, to that same kid because at that point
they'll have gone down a path or may have
gone down a path where the options for how
you can serve them are so greatly diminished.
So again this is why the idea of waiting till
your later in your career to make that difference
fundamentally, like, is gonna mean that you
have less of an impact than if you start today.
This is my highly-technical economics graph
to show that. Which basically shows, I gotta
redo it, it's terrible. The bottom orange
line represents sort of the trajectory of
an issue, right, so it could be global warming,
it could be some kid's life. And basically,
if you start your intervention early in that
timeline and you have that trajectory, you
actually end up making a much bigger difference
versus if you start with that same intervention
or a similar one later on in that life cycle,
like you don't end up making as big an impact.
And it's not just due to the effort, it has
to do with the trajectory of that, that return.
And this is really important I think to just
understand the present value of service, not
to wait another month, not to wait another
year, not to wait till you retire, but knowing
that a small thing now will have a bigger
impact than a big thing later. Any questions
about the uh, this graph? The continuum with
the cosign of it is?
So I wanted to talk a little bit about, this
is a specific issue, education, which is something
that I care a lot about 'cause I have kids.
But just to give you a sense of like the diversity
of skills that non-profits, whether it's you
know a school, whether it's a non-profit,
whether it's a government agency, what they
need from people like yourselves. This is
just a representative sample, but you take
like marketing, right? Non-profits are in
desperate need for marketing because they
do incredibly great work and Stanley can back
this up, they do great work, but you wouldn't
often know from reading their materials they
do great work. Like there's such a huge delta
between the reality of their work and the
materials and the way they describe what they
do. And it's partially a resources issue,
but it's also, I used to work in the technology,
and it's also the engineering problem. Engineers
aren't good at marketing their own wares,
because they think every little detail matters
and they have trouble figuring out what the
thing is that like is the real selling point,
right? Similarly, if you're a non-profit program
manager who's doing work with people, you
think every little thing you do for them is
like so important that you couldn't possibly
leave that piece out, and therefore you become
a terrible spokesperson because you don't
know what the real core story is, right? So
having marketers come into an organization,
help tell the stories, figure out what the
core messaging is, to tell that amazing story,
is incredibly powerful.
Management. So few non-profit executives have
training in management. Very few for-profit
ones for that matter as well, but it's even
worse in the, the non-profit sector. And you
know, and strategy, and being able to put
together a real strategy, being able to really
do the research behind the strategy, to be
able to do the people management of an organization
it could so resource constraints. So being
able to help bring that kind of thinking and
mentorship. And mentorship is one of the best
ways to do that.
Information technology. I mean we talked about
sales force, that's a great example where
so many non-profits you go into are still
using Excel spreadsheets to manage all their
donors. Which works when you have like 10
of them, but it gets to a point like at around
13½ where it just becomes impossible to manage.
So they need people to help with technology.
It's much better than it was 10 years ago,
but there's still so much need at a basic
level and then at a transformational level
there's even more opportunities around rethinking
your programs and how do you actually, like,
run your organization in a different way by
leveraging technology?
Design. This goes to that same point about
marketing. If you look at the logo or the
actual visuals of a typical non-profit, it
often looks like it was done by a high school
student and yet the work they're doing is
like a post-doctorate, like, incredible sophistication.
And it's such a crime, because I think it
not only serves them poorly, but it actually
erodes confidence overall in non-profits,
'cause we tend to think that that represents
the quality of the work they do, and it doesn't.
It actually hurts our society at a much broader
level, not having that kind of design resource
for non-profits.
And then finally HR. This is one that's like
a personal passion for me just because non-profits
are fundamentally in a people business, but
so few of them have the systems to support
their people effectively. We did a focus group
a couple years ago with about ten non-profit
executive directors, so the CEOs. And we just
asked, how many of you have ever worked in
an organization that have like a, like a functioning
HR department? Not one of them raised their
hand. There's just a fundamental issue of
not having, even seeing what it looks like
to even know what the systems are. And I'm
the first one to criticize a lot of HR practices
that are overwrought, cause all kinds of issues.
But there's some really core pieces just around
doing performance reviews and setting that
up and helping set goals for people. Making
sure you're optimizing what their benefits
can be. Like sort of training about how to
be a manager. There are some really core things
that organizations don't even actually know
how to access those resources and being able
to bring an HR professional to do an audit
of their overall HR practices and suggest
some of the key ways they could move forward
is transformational for them.
So any, has anyone done any of this kind of
work for non-profits? Seth has. A little bit?
What a great opportunity for you guys to get
out later this afternoon and do some of it.
But this is so critical. This stuff is so
needed and unlike doing traditional volunteerism,
it has a much greater impact, which goes to
my two friends here. Jill and Jim. So this
is based on data that's out there now, just
talking about if you're gonna do service,
why doing service, using your skills is so
valuable. And Jill, she works at Google. She's
smart. She does pro bono service. Jim over
here works somewhere else, not quite as swift.
And he does volunteering by painting things,
right? So the data shows that Jill provides
six times more value than Jim. So when she's
using her skills to do work in the community,
she is providing literally six times more
value for society than Jim. She is three times
more likely to gain material job-related skills,
so actually learn things about how to be better
at her job, and she's five times more likely
to make an impact overall, where is it? Social
impact as Jim's company like overall as part
of the broader program. On the flip side,
Jim over here, he's 25 percent less likely
to develop new internal relationships. You
actually build more relationships internally
in your company by working with your peers
on skilled projects than if you do it for
non-skilled work. Jim is less likely to be
satisfied with his experience. This is surprising
because people often say, yeah, I should do
skilled, but like, I want to get out there
and just, you know, enjoy the sun. I want
to something different, it'll be a lot more
fun. But people actually report having, being
much more satisfied when they're using their
skills, 'cause they know they're making a
bigger impact, they're more engaged and they
still get the psychic rewards. And most importantly,
Jim is 100 percent more likely to get paint
on his suit. Which probably is not as much
of an issue here, 'cause I don't think anyone's
wearing a suit. But you have some nice t-shirts
and sweatshirts and stuff, so it applies the
same way. So this again, as you think about
both for Google as a company but each of you
individually, leveraging your skills is just,
from a business standpoint, from a personal
standpoint just a much better value proposition
for you in terms of going out there and doing
stuff. Any questions about that? Does anyone
debate like the 100% paint on the suit stat
or anything? Not one. Ok.
So I wanna give you a quick sense of where
the state of pro bono is. So as Kristy generously
shared, I've been leading this movement around
pro bono service and I wanted to give you
a sense of where we've come and where this
is now and Seth knows some of this stuff.
Hopefully, can you guys in the back read this
ok? Probably not, but you can pretend. Be
generous. I just want to share a couple of
these statistics that I think are really interesting,
just to catch your imagination. On the left
here you see the number of projects delivered
by CreateAthon's 73 agencies. It's 2500. So
CreateAthon is a program where ad agencies
basically shut down for 24 hours. So basically
from 9 a.m. till 9 a.m. the next day, like
literally around the clock. And they bust
out websites, logos, brochures, annual reports
for non-profits. And they have 73 different
ad agencies that have signed up for this and
have delivered over 2500 projects for non-profits.
And it's amazing, like the people on this
just love it, 'cause it's like such a great
team-building activity to all get together.
So one thing you can think about is like getting
a group of your colleagues together and just
thinking about like what could you do in a
24-hour sort of sprint helping non-profits
around something. There's another technology
one called the Nerdery, which I think is a
fabulous name, out of Minneapolis, that does
this around technology, and they just do 24-hour
sort of just builds. I'm gonna go over here
to the five percent in this bubble. AIGA,
which is the American Institute for Graphic
Arts, so it's the trade association of graphic
artists, they've set a goal now that all graphic
designers and graphic design firms should
give five percent of their billable time to
pro bono service. So you're seeing this starting
to actually get adopted by the professions
who are at large, like in a really fundamental
way. I mean five percent is a lot of, a lot
of time, especially for a services business.
Twenty. The number of top 25 business schools
that have pro bono programs. So were getting
to the point now where just about every business
school is making pro bono part of the experience
of getting an MBA. And we're gonna start having
more and more students graduating who expect
to be able to do pro bono in their work. It's
incredibly exciting. Capital One is a company
that's done an incredibly great job at this.
Capital One started this a couple of years
ago in '08 and they've served 125 non-profits
through their company. It's not a consulting
firm, it's a bank, a credit card company and
a bank. But they actually set it up so each
of their departments, like technology, legal,
real estate, etc. each took on a couple projects
a year for local non-profits. And it was a
really, it's a really fabulous model and it's
coordinated across the whole company, but
it enabled them to make a real difference
in the different fields and it has the heads
of each of those departments really taking
ownership in a really powerful way. I want
to share the two, I think, most challenging
stats. The first is the bottom here it says
three percent. That's the percentage of non-profits
that report having access to the pro bono
services they need. So only three percent
of non-profits in this country feel they have
the resources they need on a pro bono basis
to help them achieve their missions, right?
Like that's a pretty depressing thought, right?
Or huge opportunity. On the opposite side
here are the word access. The number one barrier
of non-profits to getting more pro bono is
access. If you're a non-profit executive director,
you don't know which companies offer what,
you don't know who to ask, you don't know
how to scope and state what your need is.
So there's a huge need, not just for pro bono,
but for helping non-profits really gain access.
So one of the things you could do individually
is just mentor a non-profit to help them think
about what are all their needs and think about
in your network, whether it's a virtual network
or your, through people you work with, how
to help them source and get those people to
meet that need. So that simple act of being
a matchmaker and helping them gain access,
solves for a huge part of this three percent
problem. 'Cause in our experience people want
to do pro bono, they just don't, no one ever
asks them, so they don't know where to go.
So helping to be that matchmaker is incredibly,
incredibly powerful. Taproot Foundation at
this point, you see here in the bottom middle,
we've done over a million hours of pro bono
service using pro bono consultants from across
the country for non-profits. It's been incredibly
rewarding just to work with these thousands
of business professionals that each give 100
hours of their time to help a local non-profit
in the arts, education, the environment, etc.
And that's really where we learned about how
to make this all work. We also now, and Stanley
and I were just talking about this, we now
work with over 25 companies where they hire
us to help them build their own pro bono programs,
'cause we realize no matter how big we are,
we'll never be big enough, so we are working
with companies to help them build their own
programs, so that they can help the sector.
'Cause this three percent, I mean if Taproot
was wildly successful, we might get to that
to like four percent, five percent. Like we'll
never be big enough. But if companies adopt
this, we can really make a difference there,
so we see a lot of growth there. Any questions
on any of? So my challenge to you, and then
I'm gonna open up for questions, I find that
much more engaging by definition. I know you
guys recently launched Google+, which is fantastic,
even though no one's invited me to be a member
of it, goddammit.
[laughter]
>>Aaron Hurst: Clearly labeled as a late adopter,
I guess. Or very unnetworked. But I want to
challenge you to think a little bit differently
about the definition of this and think about
it more in terms of yourself and think about
what you do at Google, but what you should
do plus, sort of as a plus on top of that,
right? So you have what you do every day again
from 7 a.m. till midnight, but to think about
you know what you do with that plus. What
is the plus that you wanna have in your life
to really make yourself that parent who has
a great answer for their kids, but also to
be able to satisfy the seven year old inside
you that's asking, you know, are you on the
path, are you doing and being the change that
you wanna see? Are you proud of who you are
as a total person and are you really learning,
earning and returning every day, and if not,
how do you get that plus to be part of your
experience as a Googler? So. With that I would
love to open it up to any questions people
may have, if any, I don't know. Don't want
to force questions.
>>male #1: What's your e-mail address for
a plus invitation?
>>Aaron Hurst: It's Aaron, aaron@taprootfoundation.org.
Sweet. I'm gonna be busy the rest of the afternoon
figuring out what to do with that, so, thank
you. Yeah, please.
[audience laughs]
>>female audience member #5: What is the,
what is the access point for [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: Yeah, another great question.
So I think there's a, Taproot definitely is
always looking for marketing, HR, strategy,
finance professionals in the bay area, D.C.,
New York, Chicago and LA. So you know we'd
love to have you come join us and be part
of that. I think alternatively, you know,
think about who you know that are on non-profit
boards and ask them, like are there needs
that they have or is there any way you could
help, is there a way you could do it on a
personal level? Seth is there anything like
at Google you could point them to or I should
be?
>>Seth: I think we're, we're building up [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: So, and I was reminded that
the microphone, I need to make sure for the
people not here that to repeat that, so. The
original question was how to get involved
and I'd asked Seth sort of what are the opportunities
through Google? And Seth's really working
to try to get more of a formal pro bono program
up at Google, so the best thing you can do
to support him is harass him and all of his
chain of command, do it faster, so that we
can get that going here. But, you know, I
think Seth, also in the short term, probably
gets conversations with random non-profits
that are like, gosh I wish I had a X, Y or
a Z, so you know, I think also just letting
him know that you're interested will, it'll
help.
>>Kristy: Yeah. One quick, quick plug on that.
>>Aaron Hurst: Yeah. Plug away.
>>Kristy: So there's actually a program that's
been developed right now for sales and we're
gonna be rolling it out to the rest of the
company. It's this one percent time. Have
folks heard of this? Yeah. So, right now it
is focused on skills-based projects and there's
over 300 projects, so if folks are interested,
go to goto/onepercenttime or goto/salesonepercent
and there's a lot of stuff there, so definitely
take a look.
>>Aaron Hurst: Cool. Great plug. And sales
is a key area that non-profits need help with.
I think it's less on, it's sales skills and
it's also sales operations of like running,
like how do you do pipeline management, how
do you like manage overall to like forecast
your revenue, etc. These are really critical
skills that a lot of non-profits can really
benefit from. There was a question, yes, in
the middle there.
>>female #6: So, I [inaudible] that's really
great, but I need that fence painted. What's
your response to that? [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: So that gives a, so the question
is this Googler often goes to the schools
and churches and does volunteering, doing
more manual labor, and asks, you know says
that she is a, in technology and couldn't
they be leveraging her skills and they generally
say you know what? That fence really does
need painting, why don't you just, you know,
code that fence with some paint? You know,
I think it's an interesting, I think there's
a couple different pieces to that. I think
one is a question of who you're talking to
often and finding the right person who actually
knows where that paint point is. I think a
lot of times people don't know how to, they
don't know how to use you, so being able to
say, would it be helpful for me to come in
and do like a diagnostic upfront of just how
you're using technology overall and see coming
out of that how to help? 'Cause often they
just don't even have that upfront work done.
And it's not hard for these organizations
to find someone to paint a fence. I mean there's
VolunteerMatch. Every company's hungry to
find paints, fences to paint. I mean in fact
there's a great story of a non-profit in D.C.
who has a room that exists solely so companies
can come in and paint it, 'cause companies
are so hard up for things to paint. So they
just paint it every week a different color
as different companies come in. So I think
they had, it's not often the case they actually
don't have the access to that labor to dig
the ditches or painting. I think if you're
able to go in at a more strategic level and
say, can I help do an assessment? You'll probably
uncover it instead of saying, what can I do
just right out of the gate, 'cause they often
don't know what that entry point is. The other
problem is the sector in general has a problem
with people volunteering to help and then
trying to find jobs for you instead of vice
versa, having them say, here's what our needs
are, and then finding the people to meet that
need. And it's must easier to find people
to paint, as a general rule, because you don't
have to have specific skills. It's harder
to think about where you need people otherwise.
So the biggest, just to underscore, the biggest
value you can provide upfront is to say, you
know, you have access through Google to 26,000
amazing people. You'd love to get more of
them involved in that school. Can you help
them identify where those opportunities are
so that the next time someone says, you know,
no, just paint that fence, they can say, actually
we have all these other needs. So, I think
you can really help them cross that chasm.
Because according to all the surveys, non-profits
consistently need skilled people way more
than they need manual labor. They just don't
know how to get it or how to use it.
>>female #7: [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: Yep. It is across a lot of
different sizes and I've seen this same data
across those different, I haven't seen it
around religious organizations, but it's definitely
been the case around schools, it's been around
you know non-profits of different sizes and
their needs vary somewhat, but it's pretty
universal. And sometimes with schools and
things that are, if they're public institutions,
so actual government organizations, they may
have more rules around what they can and can't
do with volunteers, given unions, but every
school I've ever interacted with like is in
desperate need for help on like all those
fronts. It's a question of having the help
to manage it. And if you can go in and start
with the question, let me help you manage
it by figuring out what you need, you help
them unlock that potential. Yeah, Stanley.
>>Stanley: [inaudible] pro bono work in areas
that we're not experts in [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: Yep.
>>Stanley: 2010 when we got a marketing [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: So, thank you Stanley, that's
nice. In terms of, I guess I have to try to
summarize that for the, Taproot is great,
get involved. Is that? Yeah. Ok.
[laughter]
>>Aaron Hurst: I couldn't do justice to the
full spiel there, but no, I mean I think we've
really spent the last ten years creating a
model to make it really easy for you to make
a difference. And really, like start with
the non-profit's needs first, so we hope that
that you know is an opportunity if you guys
are interested that you would embrace, but
I think there's a lot of other ways to go
about doing it. Any other? No gotcha questions?
Yeah, Seth's got one. Good.
>>Seth: [inaudible] sort of something to do
with your kids?
>>Aaron Hurst: Yeah.
>>Seth: Can you talk a little bit about your
kids and how you, how do you involve them
in pro bono services? There are, are there
examples you see as you're leading this movement
in the way in which parents involve their
kids in the service that their doing. 'Cause
it's easy to go out and paint fence with my
three and a half year old, it's not as easy
to involve her in a strategic [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: You're kids probably aren't
very smart, is the reason. My kids can do
that, so I don't know what. I think that's
just, that's sort of your issue.
[laughter]
>>Aaron Hurst: Is there another question?
>>Aaron Hurst: No, no that's a great question.
I think this is one of the challenges in general
of like looking at I think the broader ethic
around pro bono is about bringing, giving
what you know and what you do best, right?
And obviously Seth, for you that's different
than my three year old son, who is really
good at killing ants and like wrestling with
kids twice his size, like those are the two
things like he's exceptionally good at. I
think that there's, I think there's two different
pieces. I think there's the issue of inspiring
your kids and being a role model. And thinking
about pro bono service in terms of a way to
be that role model, to be that hero to them
and to have that value transmitted to them
and then to find ways to have them witness
that, not just have you tell them that, so
you know if you do work for a non-profit,
see if you can bring them on a site visit
and show them. Because I think a lot of it's
not necessarily them serving as much as it
is them seeing that you value that and that
even though you're busy, like you make time
for that because you know there's always someone
less fortunate than you, no matter how bad
your circumstance is. I think that's incredibly
powerful as just a transmission of values.
I think the second piece is around them actually
doing service. And I think you have to be
really careful there again to not patronize
the non-profit sector, 'cause the sector's
not like hard up for seven year olds to come
paint fences, like that's not really what
they're looking for, but at the same time
I think there are ways to think about what
do your kids love to do? And often helping
other kids that are younger than them, like
my daughter loves doing projects. She likes
painting, she likes beading, she likes doing
all kinds of stuff and her school does a great
job of getting kids that are like a couple
grades older to come down and like teach the
kids how to do those things that they love
to do, whether it's reading, what have you,
which to me is instilling at an early age
that same idea of taking what you love, what
you know how to do well and bringing that
to, to others in sort of that sense. But it's
a, no it's an interesting challenge. I had
the same impulse too. It's like I want to,
you have a Saturday, you want to like go figure
out how to do something that you feel like
is transmitting real value. And you know I
think for some of that stuff, to be candid,
some of the direct service stuff is easier
for that. I think the challenge is, like it
puts the onus on the non-profits to have to
host you and that kid, because very few volunteer
activities really are best suited for especially
smaller children. I think as they get older,
that tends to vary, so, I don't know. But
my, my daughter is a bad ass, so she's got,
she's got, we live in Brooklyn and she's got
a lemonade stand that she puts up pretty regularly.
I'm doing a documentary on it, 'cause it's
just been like such an amazing business. She
brings in like 25 bucks an hour at 50 cents
a glass.
[laughter]
>>Aaron Hurst: Like that's a scalable amazing
business and like it's like it's phenomenal,
like I think a couple of the local bars are
like worried they're gonna have to go out
of business soon because of like the amount
of business she's been taking, so. She's not
that far off at five I think from being able
to do some business strategy for you guys
here.
[laughter]
>>Aaron Hurst: Any final questions? Yeah,
Seth.
>>Seth: I'm also [inaudible] so we get a lot
of people who say, I wanna do something different
than my, what I do during my day job [inaudible]
>>Aaron Hurst: Yep.
>>Seth: You talked about the present value
of service, you talked about the [inaudible]
You must get that often where people say,
like, I get it, I know that my skills are
more valuable doing what I'm professionally
good at, but I work 60 hours a week doing
that and I want to do something different
when I'm doing my service time.
>>Aaron Hurst: I'd fire 'em. Like if they
don't love their job and what they do enough
to wanna like do that in the community, like
they clearly aren't very good at what they
do. That's my sense of it. But, no I think
it has to, I think there are people who really
are trying to like use it as an escapism,
right? But I think, you know I think there
is that percentage of the population, but
I find though consistently is when people
actually go and use their skills and do it
in a completely different setting that it
turns them upside down. They're surprised
by how much they love that and how it feels
very different from work. And I think it's,
you know you talk about, I talked with my
executive coach about sort of in life you
need your three places. You've got your family,
you've got your work and then you need that
third place. And I think you know often people
are looking for that third place and their
looking at like I don't wanna do this stuff
at work, I want a third place. But I think
what I've seen is that people actually have
a much more rewarding third place when they
bring their whole selves to that experience.
They're not checking out their brain, they're
not checking out like you know their intellectual
passion, they're bringing that fully to the
full. So it's counterintuitive at first because
they're like trying to create a place away
from work. They're trying to carve out that
third place. But realizing that their love
for marketing or coding or HR, they've often
never had the chance to express that in a
non-commercial setting and realize how radically
different that feels when you're doing it
in that kind of environment and I can't tell
you the number of times like people said it's
the most rewarding experience in their career.
How many times people feel like they've learned
like ways to do things in completely different
ways. It's changed their identity 'cause they
go from thinking marketing as a commercial
thing to suddenly realizing that you know
they are marketing or technology that doesn't
mean that they're a business professional.
It means that they are a marketing professional
and that can be translated in a lot of different
ways, so my short answer, besides fire them,
would be tell them just to try it and tell
them that non-profit, tell them non-profits
are so hard up for this stuff, they've got
plenty of people to paint a fence, like they're
hard up for these needs. Try it and see how
it feels. And you know, not everything's for
everybody, but I'm surprised at the number
of people that have that sentiment and then
sort of had that turned around. Yeah. [pause]
Any final heckling? Well, thank you all for
making the time, I know you guys are incredibly
busy. And you know sharing your lunch hour
with me. I hope, you know, a lot of you are
able to get involved with Taproot, get involved
in other ways. Remember the present value
of service and remember that while it's easy
to always say tomorrow's gonna be an easier
day to do it, you never know what's gonna
be tomorrow, so you may as well start today.
So I just encourage you to go to our website,
look at the stories, either sign up, find
a, you know, reasons for motivation through
that and show your, show your kids what you're
doing. Show them how you are making a difference
and be a role model to them and really hold
that as your, you know your, the bar for you
and your career and your life is to be that
role model you want to be. So, thank you.
[applause]